Has anyone ever told you, "Stand up straight!"
Or scolded you for slouching at a family dinner?
Comments like that might be annoying, but they're not wrong.
Your posture, the way you hold your body when you're sitting or standing,...
...is the foundation for every movement your body makes,...
...and can determine how well your body adapts to the stresses on it.
These stresses can be things like carrying weight, or sitting in an awkward position.
And the big one we all experience all day every day: gravity.
If your posture isn't optimal,...
...your muscles have to work harder to keep you upright and balanced.
Some muscles will become tight and inflexible
Others will be inhibited.
Over time, these dysfunctional adaptations...
...impair your body's ability to deal with the forces on it.
Poor posture inflicts extra wear and tear on your joints and ligaments,...
...increases the likelihood of accidents,...
...and makes some organs, like your lungs, less efficient.
Researchers have linked poor posture to scoliosis, tension headaches, and back pain,...
...though it isn't the exclusive cause of any of them.
Posture can even influence your emotional state and your sensitivity to pain.
So, there are a lot of reasons to aim for good posture.